hey y'all
movie retrospective time we're doing
some more
cheesy 80s frank hendon lottery goodness
yeah talking about basket case
yeah this is the same dude that did
frankenhooker which i was pranking
hooker and brain damage
yeah and bad biology although i haven't
seen that one that was like a more
recent one
i haven't seen brain damage either i
don't think i thought we watched it
which one was that it's the one with the
guy uh that has the thing like growing
out of his
spine ailmer that little like he's like
a little monster and he like talks and
he like makes the guy do some i'd have
to say that again i don't think i seen
it
i was pretty sure you maybe you weren't
paying any attention i'm pretty sure
that i watched it like fairly recently
because i was going to review it
well frankenhooker was a masterpiece i
loved it and then i
and then i looked at this one again i
had seen it a couple times before but i
really didn't pay it much attention to
it
and this one also is a masterpiece it is
this is a
this is a schlock classic how could you
not love basket case this is just like
frankenhooker
even though this is a much more
obviously a much more amateurish movie
this is one of his first
was it really his first feature film i
kind of felt like i mean he made like a
lot of like shorts and other kind of
stuff like earlier than this
but you know this is nine ten years
before frankenhooker so that one was
just kind of like citizen kane
probably like you know from a production
standpoint like compared to this
one you can call it schlock if you want
to this to me this is
a very deep and sophisticated family
drama
you know it actually kind of is yeah um
there's actually a lot of kind of
touching
like pathos you know what i mean which
is like a weird thing to say
and when i say schlock i don't mean that
in an insulting way at all
i'm just saying that that's how other
people would perceive it because this
movie legitimately cost
35 000 to make and they didn't even have
it all at once
still pretty pretty basically frank
hennenlotter had eight thousand dollars
he knew another guy that was willing to
give him eight thousand dollars so they
started shooting it with sixteen
thousand and it took them so like they
would shoot
stuff until they ran out of money and
then they would like go around to
investors and be like here this is what
we shot so far we need like some more
money and then they would get like
another little trickle of money and like
film a few more scenes
so it took them like a year to make it
um this is a great move yeah i mean come
on
i love about two brothers two brothers
they were conjoined at one time
two twins and they cut them apart and
one twin
was a normal guy he could get dates and
live a normal
life the other one was just a piece of a
man ahead with [ __ ] arms and a piece
of a chest
and he's he and he was like thrown away
and you know and he's like literally
literally thrown away he's suffering you
know i mean
his brother's doing good and he's just
like stuck in the apartment going
and he kept him in a basket and [ __ ] and
he's coming up and he's [ __ ] grabbing
girls titties and trying to
try to get laid and stealing their
underwear and killing him and [ __ ] and
his
brother's trying to stop him it's a
great family drama and it ends just like
king kong
hit the ground dead everybody looking at
him the monster
you know it is it was it's a masterpiece
it
this movie is like it's it's cheap as
[ __ ] obviously but it's it's a lot of
fun
i remember seeing this movie when i was
gosh i was probably like a pre-teen or a
teenager because it came out in 1982
um when i was 10 years old i probably
saw it maybe a couple years after that
so maybe like in the mid 80s and me and
my younger brother
loved this [ __ ] movie a lot of
charming aspects about this
there is there's just this sleazy yeah
random people
acting yeah you just pick some random
people can you be in this
yeah yeah and they actually cut they
actually pull it off
but you can tell it's random people a
lot of them and then the special effects
they're not gray but they're they're
pretty good
you know what i mean uh first chief as
this movie was yeah pretty
i've seen i've seen worse in movies more
expensive than this
it's not supposed to be realism it's
just supposed to be creepy
and it is creepy it's very creepy
and it's kind of creepy and cartoonish
that but that's that's all it needs
realism might make it not fun
that's just that way i was thinking it
you know i mean like it doesn't
it's practical effects and some of the
[ __ ] look
i had the little puppet yeah belial
belial
sometimes i thought it was actually a
real person looking through a mask with
two hands
uh that's how good the eyes looked
sometimes and then they'd light it it's
just weird
it might well i'm not sure because i'm
pretty sure that it was always a puppet
um except when you saw it like moving
around then it was stop motion stop
motion
and i will say that okay so frank hendon
lotter like i said he's the same guy
that made frankenhooker and [ __ ] like
that
he grew up in long island new york
and he was always he [ __ ] loved
you know grindhouse he loved all the
exploitation movies he loved like going
to the
42nd street like back in new york city
when new york city was just a sleaze pit
and just seeing all these like [ __ ] up
type of movies
and we've talked about this before like
in the 70s and early 80s you know when
new york was rolled grimy and dangerous
there was some kind of like real diy
punk rock kind of aesthetic where it's
like people were going out in the
streets and just
gorilla filmmaking and making these
crazy ass movies
and they were finding an audience um
so it's it's crazy like you could just
like do whatever
and like people would be like ah cool
and then like [ __ ] see it
and you know it's kind of sad that those
days are gone but
in a way it's like really cool to see
somebody i mean when he was making this
movie
he he admitted later because i saw some
interviews with him
and he said you know i couldn't afford
to make the movie
that i wanted to make necessarily like
this what you know the script that i had
written for the movie like we couldn't
afford to do it
but he was kind of like we were just
having a good time we just wanted to
make a movie we were having fun
um we didn't really think anyone was
going to see it or would give a [ __ ] so
we were just kind of like going for
broke
um the interesting thing is that i think
now from what i could determine from
like reading stuff about them and like
watching video essays about it and stuff
like that
was that i'm pretty sure that the movie
when some uh distribution company like
picked it up
they thought it would play better as a
comedy
and so they cut out all the gore because
there is like quite a
quite a bit of gore in this they cut out
all the gore and kind of made it more
like a comedy and it didn't really do
much of anything
but apparently joe bob briggs that
wonderful
man that national treasure had seen the
movie in its
uncut form previously like what it
played in texas like a drive-in or
something
and he kind of like met with them and
said bro like why don't you know put the
gore back in there like let's do it like
on the midnight movie circuit
he started like kind of plugging it and
at that point it started playing like in
theaters all over like 42nd street and
stuff and there started to be like lines
around the block
this is back in the 80s yeah this was
like early 80s
like 82 right around there so from what
i could just like joe bob briggs was
like a big part of
why this movie became a cult classic
because he really went to bat for it and
like helped it get
well it's a good story yeah it's a good
story it is yeah
um you're like oh no really really to
keep up in the [ __ ]
game i mean about what the hell's this
thing's doing and
you got to see it to understand it it's
it's not really based on dialogue which
i think that is great it's more about
showing and not telling it's just
everything cinema is supposed to be
and it is has a lot of like i said
family drama and a lot of angst in it
and
uh you you feel for the monster but it's
still it's still a monster
um you feel for the guy who's trying to
protect the monster
it's not really their fault it's the
world and he wasn't he didn't choose to
be born
that way it's kind of like the in in
that was the same thing with king kong
king kong was just being what he was he
died
and you know what i mean the people did
it that's kind of the moral of this
story
belial was just being what he was people
killed him basically yeah it's like he
couldn't really help
like he didn't ask to be born like that
and you know he got like treated
horribly like his whole entire
little life they literally threw him
away like yeah
garbage and nobody watered him except
his brother
you know what i mean and he was a
monster he was just a piece of a body
and and he couldn't talk but he had
psychic abilities
yeah that was another thing yeah well he
had well he had telepathic abilities
with his brother telepathic link right
yeah yeah yeah
because that's kind of how the story
goes like you you start out in the
present day
and you're starting out with dwayne who
is the quote-unquote normal
brother uh he's played by kevin van
henten rick i think is how you pronounce
his last name
he has very very poofy hair almost
mullety but not quite
it's very poofy and uh he's just walking
down the streets of new york city
uh carrying a basket one of them he's
here he had that rick springfield here
rick springfield's hair wasn't quite
that poofy but it was kind of like it
was like a poofy
level right above maybe two poofy levels
i don't
if there's a level of poofiness like
hair poopiness
on the scale i had that ring spray you
did but your hair was not as poofy as
as dwayne's hair in this movie girl man
yeah
you did have hair just like that yeah
so yeah so so he's just walking the
street carrying a basket uh fun fact
like i said
you know they couldn't afford permits or
anything even in new york city like you
could
now it's super expensive to shoot there
that they always shoot in toronto
but um back then you could but you still
had to be sly about it
so all the scenes of like people walking
down the street were just like done from
a moving car
like they were just like the you know
the crew of which there were like three
people
the funny thing i didn't know this about
it but i saw like something
uh another like breakdown of this movie
and they said you know how like the end
credits like have all these different
names and stuff they're like none of
those people
exist um actually they just wanted to
make it seem more like a real movie
because there was only like three or
four people working on it like on the
crew so they just made up all these
names like to put in the [ __ ] credits
which like to me is i don't know that's
just really delightful
but yeah so i like that the first i
don't even know if it's like the first
half and i don't think it's quite as
long as half of the movie
but for the first part of the movie if
you've never seen this before there's
like suspense
because you don't really know what
what's in the basket i mean you know
that there's probably something alive in
there but he doesn't they don't
show it so it's just like this guy and
he's carrying this [ __ ] basket around
you know what it looks like you know
what you know what it is well i know but
i'm just
i'm just saying that from the point of
view
of someone who had never seen it before
like back in 1982
yeah well the first time i saw it i knew
what it was going to be i just didn't
know what it looked like what it was
well that's kind of what i meant i mean
like i said you knew that there was
something alive in there
uh because you talk to it because at
some point like he brings back some food
he's like talking to it he
takes it everywhere feeds that [ __ ] raw
hot dogs and he puts like hot dogs
a whole package of hot dogs or the first
thing he brings back is like a bunch of
hamburgers like from a place across the
street
and he just like throws them in there
and you hear
you hear like all that noise like that
which like i said sounds like pookie
eating treats
yeah because we were watching it again
last night i said oh my god that sounds
just like pookie when she eats treats
out of her little bowl
she just sounds like this little
munching noise but yeah so i think it's
cool that they because
you know people keep asking him like
what's in the basket he doesn't tell
anybody
and honestly he doesn't really tell
anybody until he gets drunk with that
uh hooker i guess she's a hooker right
yeah
her name's casey and she like lives in
the building you know what i mean i
you know what i think she might be other
than belial i think she might be my
favorite character at this moment what's
funny is that
you could tell that's a random woman
yeah she's awesome i love her
she had fantas they she she she had the
badonkadonk going and everything
she was sexy but she couldn't she
couldn't act
but she pulls it off especially the
screaming part
she's very good she became a good
actress as she went
you could tell she got more comfortable
with it you know you didn't notice that
well like i said it took them a very
long time to shoot this like over a year
so that might be why yeah she's the
hooker that lives down the street or
lives across the uh yeah because he's
come to new york i mean the whole point
of the story
is that him and belial have come to new
york to
take revenge on the doctors that
separated them because they show like a
flashback later on
they got separated when they were 12.
they were separated against their will
because one thing that happened is that
uh
the their dad was like really pissed off
not only because
he had this conjoined twin that was like
monstrous looking and the kid wasn't
normal
but also that his wife had died giving
birth to them
so that was like another strike against
them so he let them
like be that way until they were like 12
and then he decided [ __ ] this [ __ ]
like i'm just gonna have them separated
so he on the sly
gets all these doctors who you later
find out i think are veterinarians or at
least like one or two of them are
um and they come to the house and like
in the dining room
like set up a little ursats like
emergency room
and separate the twins like against
their will and
legitimately like throw belisle into a
garbage can and put him out with the
garbage
like be taken out but of course like
dwayne that's his brother they have a
telepathic link
because they were once attached so he
goes out and rescues him and then at
that point they're taken in by their
aunt
who's actually the only person who's
shown them any love and actually there's
like some really kind of
weirdly grotesquely like sweet scenes of
her like reading belial a story he's
like sitting at her lap
and she's like reading to him and stuff
but then after the ant dies
which is when you know the start of the
movie is that's when they come to new
york and they decide
it's mostly belial's idea i think um
that we're gonna go to new york and
we're gonna get revenge on the doctors
that did this to us
because there's kind of just a whole
through line in this movie
of you know um dwayne
you know he looks pretty normal other
than he has like a really bad scar
on his side obviously where belial was
removed but other than that
he looks completely normal so he could
have a normal life but the fact that he
won't
leave belial behind him he won't betray
his brother you know what i mean but
there's still like a lot of tension
between them because he
in a way like once he gets to new york
and he meets uh you know this girl
what's i can't remember her name is i
don't know
i think sharon and he can get laid and
blow out cancer and belial can't because
belial is only just a little flesh
blob with like one arm or i guess he has
two arms he's got two arms uh it's like
a little flipper type
yeah he just hands a little and he has
little claws he has a little
like hands that have claws on the side
of his head and he goes yeah yeah yeah
he can't really talk he's like pointy
teeth yeah yeah yeah he's got a
demonic face he looks like a demon and
they have a great scene where
his his brother's out getting laid and
[ __ ] and [ __ ] beliel sucking looking
out the window the apartment
[ __ ] shitty apartment they're in he's
just screaming at new york
[Laughter]
yeah yeah because he's frustrated he's
trapped in a [ __ ] demonic body
which is you know what i mean you feel
for it you feel for the dude you're like
that's what i mean it's like you know
you do you think you deserve it it's
just you know that's that's how you were
born you know
that's what i mean about the apartment
up and the [ __ ] people are looking
what's in there and they [ __ ] finally
busted the apartment and it's just the
basket
and they don't they didn't find him yeah
yeah that was some weird [ __ ]
although eventually he starts jumping
out killing people biting him and [ __ ]
yeah i mean he does he definitely does
like kill all the doctors
yeah um you don't feel too bad about it
because the doctors like i said they did
like separate them
uh you know and that was kind of shitty
no i wasn't shitty they were trying to
save him
well that's viable that's what the dad
said but he was already 12 years old at
that point they were already 12 years
old right
the dad was trying to save the the the
the normal
the normal okay so he could have a
normal life there yeah but what about
the other one he's basically like [ __ ]
the other one he's not really gonna have
a life anyway yeah he's just a monster
yeah he's not gonna have a life and he's
sacrificed that which that's i think
that's been done
oh i'm sure it has yeah i'm sure it has
and conjoined twins
you know but usually they've done it
very early on i think a lot of times
well yeah i think there were some that
in the 70s that they separated and one
of them died and the one that died was
the less formed one but they were just
like well
got to happen and i think they did that
because the less deformed one had
started to develop all kinds of problems
that would have ended up killing the
other one anyway
i think one dies they both don't that's
what i mean it just seems like a
horrible situation all around
you got to save one of them yeah it
might come to a point where like you
definitely have to
i don't know i kind of just got the
point but i don't know like i kind of
got the idea from this movie in
particular
that i don't think i don't think belial
was you know gonna kill the
normal kid i just think that the dad
didn't like
that the normal kid could never be
normal with
belial attached to him yeah um and it
was kind
and also like i said there was that
lingering resentment because you know
his wife had died giving birth to them
so i don't think it was even a health
issue because had it been a health issue
he probably could have gone to like a
regular hospital and
the fact that he did it like on the dl
well you're i know
in the dining room you're looking at it
you're looking at it you're looking at
it for sent from a sentimental point of
view
but actually no they should have been
separated so the guy could have had a
normal life
what they messed up from is they didn't
euthanize belial if you're gonna do that
you have to euthanize belial
you can't you know which i thought they
i thought they expected him to die
anyway it didn't look like there was
enough
of him to to live on his own well they
did expect him to die they said
they said yeah they said as soon as like
we separate them he'll probably die
because you know he's basically just
like a head in arms
like he didn't really seem to have any
um
you know organs yeah even even though he
could breathe and stuff like that like
on his own because you could hear him
going
yeah in a saying in a say in america
in a saying america there there should
be certain
types of youth in asia for certain
situations and belial would have been
one of the
one of the one of the uh would have been
a good
candidate for that problem you can't let
somebody live like that and then that
kind of suffering and that the movie was
like that
yeah it's well it's not only was his
suffering so great he was killing other
people
you can't force somebody to live like
that he just
and the dad was kind of right he was a
dick they they portrayed him as a dick
but no i wouldn't like to want to live
like that i'd rather have you put me out
yeah but like i said that's kind of why
i think that's why people are still
talking about this movie
all this all these years later even
though it's like super super cheap
it's in a lot of ways it's a horror
movie but it's also like it's a horror
comedy
yeah and it was made to be like
exploitative and it was made to be
shocking
uh which it is but it kind of
um goes into a lot of issues and like i
said we're just like talking about it
right here it's like what would really
happen to somebody that was like that
and if this situation really did arise
where
dwayne loved his brother so much that he
wasn't willing to like let him die or
leave him behind and
but at the same time you know he's still
carrying
belial around everywhere with him in
this basket and he can't like have a
normal life
and it's belial's idea or so we're led
to believe because bilal can't talk he
can only like telepathically
apparently like talk through his brother
um so it's belial's idea to go
kill all the doctors that were
responsible for separating them
but belial even though he's sympathetic
because it's like i said he didn't ask
to be born like that
and he you know he's frustrated because
he can't ever have a normal life because
he looks the way he looks
but he's also holding back his
brother um one by holding on to this
rage and like revenge fantasy and he's
gonna get his brother into trouble uh
you know with that too
but he's also not letting his brother go
out and like do like he can't have a
girlfriend he can't
you know what i mean it's like you you
know you can only have with me that's
the only thing you want to know what
it's really like if something like this
would really happen
back in the very early 80s there was a
celebrity type case that was like this
and they actually i think they showed it
on geraldo or something
they had some conjoined twins that were
just [ __ ]
amazingly horrifying to look like look
at it the the two twins together just
look like a spider
there's like eight legs oh i think i
know who you're talking about yeah and
they could he could walk around like
this
and they would talk to each other and
stuff they were both
they didn't one they didn't there was no
way they could be separated
yeah you know they were just too fused
together but it looked like a spider
and um they were both mentally
handicapped
so they were happy you know what i mean
they had the minds of children really
you know they just they would just say
nonsense and [ __ ] um
but they would go down the street you
know under supervision and [ __ ] and
people would scream and run
yeah you know that's what it was like
not real no
well they were man it was it was scary
to see
you know shocking you did i don't see
how a woman could
physically give birth to that through it
must have come out of a woman
through cesarean section i don't think
that a woman could
pass that out of her body because it was
massive the baby would have been massive
and weird shaped you know
so they must have just taken it out
because before amniocentesis was real
common
and it lived but there would have been
no way to separate it
yeah but there was no life that normal
humans would ever live
and they like i said they mentally
didn't develop too well
they would just kind of talk to each
other and just make nonsensical jokes
and [ __ ] they seemed to be happy but
they didn't really
also didn't seem very to be very aware
like people would scream and run and
they wouldn't even really notice it
whatever well they probably got used to
it after a while yeah there's
they probably maybe didn't even know it
was anything to do with them which like
i said is probably like the best uh
thing for them yeah and i i don't even
know if you you could probably find
video of them it's pretty disturbing i
remember
i think i remember like who you're
talking about yeah they died that was
a pretty famous case yeah i don't think
they lived that long they didn't i think
they they were dead by the time they
reached their 30s i think
yeah but yeah so i mean so the thing
about it it's just like funny that we're
getting into this like serious
discussion about this when we're talking
about this movie
but you know as cheap as this movie was
as exploited of his movie it was even
though it's essentially like i said a
horror comedy it's not as
it's not quite as funny as frankenhooker
um because it kind of has more of a
serious
tone to it and i but i really like
i really like like the whole personality
of because it looked like
like you said these were just like new
yorkers um you know like the guy that
runs the fleabag hotel
you know the hookers the girlfriend it's
like none of them are really actors or
like really amateurish
but there's still like a charm about it
and you could tell that they were having
a really good time
like making this movie and so it's
really like this time capsule
of like shitty gross like 42nd street
new york
and just all these kind of characters
that are like
in this like on the margins of society
kind of
and it's like it really has that charm
to it that you really can't
replicate nowadays yeah we watched
another one recently called unnamable
that [ __ ]
yeah we're gonna we're gonna do it later
it didn't play that well but this movie
was kind of the opposite of that
you could tell the budget wasn't that
big yeah but it was very very watchable
because it had a really good story
it had a lot of good action the edit was
really good
the story continued along at a certain
pace so you could understand what was
going on
it had a good score and good sound
effects and good special effects
all within the limitations of its budget
but overall when you watched it
it was good it was like it was like
watching a movie of a much higher budget
when you kind of think about it
yeah i mean you could definitely tell i
mean much the way
they cared about it yeah and that's
that's what i'm saying and that really
does kind of come
through makes a big difference in these
types of movies you can tell that you
know this is really something
everybody wanted to make and everybody
was really having a good time the woman
that played casey i think she's
like the the hooker from across the hall
yeah who like i said is probably other
than bilal is probably the best
character in this because she's just so
i mean obviously she's not an actress
but she's just so she's just such a
great she's just such a nice person
and that really kind of comes across
because she's kind of the only one
that cares about dwayne and the like he
looks out for him and stuff like that
because he's just this naive he's never
been in new york city
before he's like flashing wads of cash
around because he doesn't
you know he's never had any like uh idea
that anyone was gonna like
steal it and stuff so it's like she kind
of takes him under her wing a little bit
and kind of befriends him
and he's like uh she's the first person
really the only person that he tells
about
uh belial even though um she doesn't
believe it
because why would you that's like yeah
i'm carrying this little like
chewed gum like little person like
around in a basket
and he uh occasionally jumps out and
kills people in really horrible graphic
ways
and just like stays in the hotel room
and screams and stuff but there's just
like something so so charming about
i even love the stop motion which frank
hannenlatter did the stop motion and he
had never done it before
um he did that one scene where like
belial's trash in the hotel rooms like
kind of run around the hotel room
and he thought it looked really bad so
he's like okay well we'll just do the
whole thing for with puppets from now on
but i really really like the stop motion
i mean i think it's like it's good for
like never having done stop motion
probably much better than i could have
done i'm sure
but it's just effective yeah that's what
i mean and and honestly
the the belial puppet is real
i think it's really good i think it's
like really effective it looks really
kind of creepy yeah it looks like it
kind of looks expensive in a way
it does i think i mean when you think of
her how cheaply this movie was made
you could put it up there like from
beyond a reanimator
it's it's as watchable as those two
movies yeah yeah
it's just super fun like i said it's
just a cheap
you know this grimy [ __ ] new york
gorilla making so like i said you can't
really do any more because like one
new york doesn't really look like that
anymore frankenhooker was a little more
fun i think because it was funny
yeah this one has this one has funny
bits to it yeah but it's serious
but with the implications of it are
actually like kind of serious
yeah because you're like you know what
would really happen in this situation
and
like i said even though belial is a
monster and like kills people and stuff
you still feel bad for him because like
you said he didn't ask to be born like
that
and you know his brother saved him which
is awesome but
now it's just like he can't really he
will never be able to have a normal life
and that's very frustrating for him so
you can like understand like where he's
coming from also
it's a conjoined twin horror story yeah
uh but yeah so the fact that people are
still talking about all these years
later which is hilarious because frank
cannon lotter said we were just making
it first kind of shits and giggles
because we wanted to make a movie and
like we didn't think anybody would see
it
we thought maybe it would play like two
weeks and some [ __ ] run down theater
and then everyone forget about it
and i'm like and meanwhile uh they made
like two sequels to this you know that
right uh they made uh basket case two
and basket case three the progeny uh
basket case two
i have i've seen it but it was a long
time ago i've seen like clips of it
recently
it's essentially the same story but um
you know kind of more it looks a lot
more polished
it's good but it's like not it doesn't
have the charm of the first one because
it's not like all gritty and gross
and the thing about it is that because i
remembered there being sequels when we
were watching it last night i'm like
don't they both die at the end
uh yeah they both die at the end so i'm
kind of like well how'd they work that
out but they just made it at the end so
it's like they didn't
quite die they were just like laying
there and they're all busted up and
everything
yeah so you know and uh i think like the
the sequels
from what i've heard i haven't seen the
third one but i just like the sequels
get like more and more batshit like you
know there's
of course they have to introduce like a
female equivalent to belial so like the
two little
like deformed puppets can have sex with
each other
uh that's kind of par for the course
with these types of movies so it's just
kind of because there is one very
disturbing scene in the first one
where belial is trying to uh
maybe succeeding in raping dwayne's
uh potential girlfriend yeah she was
dead wasn't she
was yeah well yeah that was like really
[ __ ] up i think she was alive for a
time and then he killed her but then he
kept on going
yeah worth seeing amazing rack amazing
should have a very nice wreck
yeah uh that yeah that girl uh was like
that
that girl was like super funny like
she's she's really like not a good
actress but in a way
that still makes it like super funny
like watching her you know what i mean
she works as the receptionist in one of
the doctor's offices of the doctors that
he's going to kill
so that's how he meets her movie also
kind of reminds me of the move
of that one movie where the the guy
who's the abortion who survived the
being aboard it comes back home
in some ways it kind of reminds me red
christmas yeah right it almost
for some reason because it was kind of
disgusting yeah
that kind of reminds me that was a
fairly recent movie red christmas dee
wallace was in it that's a pretty [ __ ]
up movie if you want to watch that
yeah put you in the holiday spirit
worst case conjoined twin story is
like a horror story i think the only
thing closest to it in real
life would have been the spider-man
conjoined twins they were pretty [ __ ]
and then on the other end of the
spectrum the two that two-headed girl
she's still alive you ever seen her
yeah yeah she looked pretty normal yeah
that's that's which is that's weird man
it's she's
looks like a two-headed girl it's two
girls conjoined yeah
you know i mean the torso is a little
wider
than normal it's two torsos yeah but
they can walk around drive cars and
everything just one head next
they look they look exactly like the
little twins yeah nick talk
normal intelligence you know went to
high school they were popular
man could you imagine i would the thing
that always
would be like leave me alone [ __ ] that
but see that's what i thought it's like
you could never like can i have some
time to myself please no there's no such
thing
it's like you'd have to like drug the
other one it's like hey can you like you
know go to sleep for a while so i can
like have some time to myself
if you date one you're in a constant
threesome
pretty much yeah like i said there's a
lot of there's a lot of like [ __ ] up
[ __ ] and
yeah you know it's i'm sure they get
those kind of questions all the time
because people are just like naturally
curious and like not
you know not to be shitty about it but
people are like curious how you navigate
like
particular like sensitive situations one
controls one leg and one controls the
other hand you know what i mean like
each head controls the other side of the
body wow that'd be fun i think that too
i think it's like now we're going
walking walking is like a joint
yeah thing for them so they have to like
cooperate
yeah but evidently they were doing
sports and [ __ ] if i remember i saw a
program and
it looked like it was running around
normally you just your
the mind is incredible you can adapt
yeah i mean you know that's that's one
good thing that's kind of like
inspirational right yeah but yeah this
this story not so much
no and there was another story i don't
know if it's true or not
but in the victorian era they believed
it was true
some guy who came from a rich family
that
evidently was rumored to have a face on
the back of his head
oh i heard yeah yeah yeah and he thought
he could hear what it was saying it was
constantly cursing him
and yeah yeah he threw hair over it so
no one else could see him i remember
that
cursing for that [ __ ] and the doctors
couldn't remove it it was part of his
[ __ ] skull it was just a little face
and they said the lips would move and
his eyes would move a little bit
there's a face of an infant he
eventually blew his head off now i don't
know if it's a true story
i mean that's not crazy because i have
seen you know
that i have seen that happen like
medically where like there's another
kind of face on
you know it appeared in stories
in the newspapers yeah of the time and
there's a lot of there was a lot of fake
news back then
i don't know if it's true or not yeah
it's probably hard to tell it's
a juncture but like i said it's not
crazy to think that that could have
happened because
conjoined yeah because i've seen similar
i've seen similar the brain tissue might
be connected so maybe you could hear the
thoughts
yeah that like i said that's totally not
all right that's not without the
the the balance of possibility when
belial was doing the mental link with
them i thought that's where they got
that concept
because that it might have been yeah
drove him according to the newspapers
and the stories
that it's cursing him drove him crazy
because it was just constantly like you
suck yeah back there kind of
well you know whatever the victorian
equivalent was so maybe that's where he
got the idea from
like that story because it's i had heard
that story so it's pretty common
right um whether that was a real guy or
not i can't really remember now i have
to like look it up
because that's what i thought he got
that whole idea
yeah because they well they describe in
the movie like they said when they were
still attached
they didn't have to talk because they
could telepathically talk to each other
but once they were separated um it only
went one way like belial could
telepathically communicate with duane
but not the other way around
so they could like kind of see um you
know they they kind of like saw each
other's dreams and like that kind of
[ __ ]
so he could like but he could sort of
see through belial's eyes
because because remember when belial was
at there like raping and killing his
girlfriend
he was having a dream about that that he
was actually realized and he woke up and
he realized that he was seeing what
belial was doing at that point but based
on my memory of that victorian case
that's where i think he got the idea for
this uh but like i said somebody might
want to check into it
maybe we'll do a show on it or something
i don't know if that actually happened
or if that's an apocryphal tale yeah
we'll have to like look that right
but yeah seriously basket case if you're
into horror especially like you know
schlocky
early 80s or you really owe it to
yourself to watch this like i said
just it's super fun it's super [ __ ] up
it's pretty gory it's also got like some
really funny moments in it
like i said the acting is not great it's
just you know it looks
bad because it's like was 16 millimeter
and then it was blown up
and it's just kind of like but there's
just some kind of charm you can tell
that everybody was having a good time
they
you know they loved exploitation cinema
and they were just so happy to be making
one
that it really like makes up for all of
the shortcomings and
turns them uh honestly takes the
shortcomings and turns them into
assets that's what i'm saying yeah it's
five out of five yeah it's entertainment
yeah it's a super fun movie and if
anybody has seen uh the sequels let me
know if they're any good i saw the
second one and i remember it being
pretty good but it's been a long time
since i've seen it and i don't think
i've ever seen the third one
um but i'm kind of curious to watch them
now now that we've rewatched basket case
basket case i think is on 2b it's also
on shutter um
so you know check it out if you haven't
seen it and like i said a lot of love to
joe bob briggs for
uh kind of making this one into a cult
classic
that people are still talking about
nowadays because i found all kind of
like horror channels that reviewed this
one like younger guys everything like
that from just the past couple years
so people are still watching it talking
about it nowadays which is [ __ ] crazy
for a 35 thousand dollar
movie that they made back in the early
80s but yeah so
anyway that'll do it for this movie
retrospective and we will see you guys
on the next one
bye